reason that making the first hundred  thousand dollars is the hardest is that  you have no leverage you don't have  money to buy other people's time you  don't have nearly as much money to buy  skills you have less money to buy media  and so you have to physically do and  learn all of the little pieces of  growing your business but once you have  the first hundred thousand dollars you  can pull off the gas a little bit  because then you can start deploying  that and that money can start working  for you not through investments but  within your business and getting  leverage on other people's time and  start buying your own time back